Times have been tough for the Dutton clan
over the first two seasons of Paramount Network's
breakout Western drama Yellowstone, but they've
apparently been even tougher on series headliner
Kevin Costner.
From the sound of it, Costner has recently
been having some second thoughts about signing
onto Yellowstone.
The actor recently sat down with Indiewire
to talk about the show's recently-wrapped
second season, and to hear him tell it, he's
not enjoying certain aspects of the modern
cowboy drama's production.
Outside of the rigorous shooting schedule,
Costner's biggest issue with Yellowstone is
apparently that he often feels left in the
dark in regards to his character's past, and
where Dutton is headed emotionally from episode
to episode.
Costner told Indiewire:
"I'm not always privy to [aspects of the character's
arc], no.
Sometimes with [Dutton's] sons or wife or
whatever, that's been really kept in a creative
ball.
That's a more vulnerable way to go through
life as an actor."
Given the rash of melodramatic twists and
turns that have accompanied seemingly every
new episode of Yellowstone over the show's
first two seasons, it's easy to understand
why Costner might want a little more info
about his character, after all, it would be
difficult for any actor, even one of Costner's
caliber, to navigate all that madness with
any kind of emotional honesty.
For Costner in particular, Yellowstone has
proven an even bigger challenge, because he's
spent the bulk of his decades-long career
starring in feature films, which allow actors
to study the entirety of their self-contained
storylines, and plot out their characters'
arcs from start to finish.
Hard as it is to believe, Yellowstone is only
the second television series Costner has ever
starred in, with the first being the limited,
three episode run of the History Channel mini-series
Hatfields & McCoys.
In spite of Yellowstone's breakout success,
Costner still hasn't gotten used to the vulnerability
that comes with not knowing what lies ahead
for his character.
During his interview, Costner bluntly stated:
"It hasn't been an easy adjustment for me.
I don't like it too much."
While this may lead fans to believe that Costner
has designs on skedaddling from Yellowstone,
thankfully, this isn't the case.
"Well ain't that the thing about problems,
Dutton.
No matter how long you’re gone, they'll
be right here when you get back."
Given the series' impressive viewership numbers,
Costner is enjoying as large an audience as
he has at any point in his storied career;
Yellowstone is one of the most-watched series
on cable television, and its ratings hit an
all-time high with the season 2 finale.
Though Costner may never quite adjust to the
rigorous shooting schedule and the sometimes
cloudy narrative of the series, he's still
very much the star of a hit show, and is a
crucial part of why fans keep coming back
from one week to the next.
As it happens, the showrunners are reportedly
mapping out the show's fourth run of episodes
already, and may have as many as seven full
seasons of Yellowstone in the works, and there's
little doubt that they want Costner in the
saddle for as long as he can ride.
For proof of that, look no further than the
actor's astonishing $500,000 per episode salary,
because nothing says "we love you" quite like
a good payday.
Seriously, put this into perspective: Yellowstone
ran for nine episodes in its first season,
and was bumped up to 10 episodes for season
2.
If the episode order stays at ten, and Yellowstone
does indeed run for a full seven seasons,
it would finish its run with 69 episodes,
which means Costner stands to net a whopping
$34.5 million for his work on the show.
Of course, given that the role of the duplicitous
Dutton is an exceedingly complex one, it's
unlikely that Costner will get bored with
the gig anytime soon, either, and that can
only be a good thing.
However they do it, though, you can be certain
Yellowstone's creative team will do everything
in their power to ensure that Kevin Costner
is roping, ranching, and scheming on the small
screen for the foreseeable future.
The series' highly anticipated third season
is expected to premiere on Paramount Network
in the summer of 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.